for the record it's not really my final
yep you heard it from Meredith gray
herself Ellen Pompeo teases this
upcoming episode of Gray's Anatomy isn't
her last you don't have to do that thing
where you know I say something and then
you say something and then somebody
cries and there's like a moment yeah
the news comes after she announced she's
officially scrubbing out from the hit
medical drama after 19 Seasons but Ellen
tells E.T next week's winter Premiere
won't be mayor's final appearance it's a
little bit about the trick they're
playing on people
um it is my final episode for a while
but tonight I haven't more important
engagement I'm having dinner with Martha
Stewart so you know listen Martha trumps
everyone
so I have a dinner date we're
celebrating her
Valentine late Valentine's Day date
on Wednesday Ellen traded scrubs for
Couture hitting Michael Kors New York
Fashion Week show with her
eight-year-old daughter Sienna it's not
her first passport show actually no how
many have you been to uh two
scored major Mama points by sitting next
to Leah Michelle
Ellen's worn Michael's designs many
times so it's no surprise she made sure
to be there to check out his latest
collection you know I've known Michael
first so long he was one of the first
people to embrace me when I started my
career so I'll always show up for him
and I love classic American fashion it's
really nice I love thank you so much he
genuinely is such a kind person and fun
to be with we used to go to the Met Ball
together and we had the best times
[Music]